every video until now we've been working
from the assumption that the observable
universe is smaller than the entire
universe and if you go by the cosmic
inflation Theory cosmic inflation theory
and it was come up or it was founded by
Alan Guth and I have a almost personal
connection to Alan Guth when I was at
MIT I always used to go to this Chinese
food truck and I always used to show up
at the food truck like two seconds
before Alan Guth like he was always one
or two people behind me in line but
anyway he was the founder of the cosmic
inflation theory which is basically this
idea at the very early in the very early
moments or the very early period after
the Big Bang we went through kind of
this major inflation in the expansion of
space but anyway if based on cosmic on
on the theory of cosmic inflation then
the observable universe is on the order
of or maybe another way to say it the
entire universe is on the order of 10 to
the 23 times the size size of the
observable universe observable universe
so that would mean this is just a tiny
tiny fraction I mean this is an
unimaginably large number in fact it is
unimaginable so already everything we've
talked about this itself is a huge this
is an incomprehensible amount of space
but this is an incomprehensible multiple
of this incomprehensible amount of space
and that's just based on that theory but
it is possible we cannot rule out even
the idea that the actual universe is
smaller smaller than the observable
universe and now that that one that one
is in some ways even more mind-blowing
than the idea that the universe is this
big the fact that what we're observing
is actually larger than the actual
universe and so you might tomato salad
that's impossible but just just think
about a little bit this is the
observable universe and the way we've
depicted it it's based on how long the
light has taken to reach us we've
already covered before that this point
in space is now 46 billion light years
away not 13.7 the way it looks right
over here
it just took 13.7 billion years to reach
us if there's any photon that would take
longer than 13.7 billion years to reach
us it hasn't reached us yet because it
could have only started 13.7 billion
years ago so they're there they're on
their way and they're they started at
some point outside of our observable
universe so our observable universe will
grow over time but with that said let's
imagine that the actual universe is a
subset of this observable universe let's
say it's let's say it's roughly half the
diameter so let's say it looks like this
maybe I'll make it a little bit of an
oval maybe observe maybe the actual
universe and this is just to be a little
bit provocative and it's not impossible
this is let's say that this is the
actual universe actual universe and the
way I drew it it makes it look like
Earth is the center that we're the
center of it but remember this is very
likely to be the surface or it is it is
curved it has a slight curvature but it
could very well be the surface of a
four-dimensional of a four-dimensional
object and maybe the simplest want to
visualize is a four-dimensional sphere
so if you really wanted to visualize
this right this whole volume and
remember this whole picture I said it
keeps looking two-dimensional but it has
depth it is a volume of space an
incredibly vast volume of space and so
what I've done here is this is a this is
a an ellipsoid right here it's an
elliptical volume of space that I've
bubbled out right over here but if we if
this was really the entire universe and
if the entire universe really were the
surface of a four-dimensional sphere
then the reality is that this entire
space could be represented like this it
could be represented as the surface if
this was a four-dimensional sphere
obviously the way I can only draw
3-dimensional spheres but let me show
you that it has some it's not just a
circle that it actually has some depth
to it and I can even shade it right over
here and so you can imagine you can
imagine that this point that this point
over here is actually the same thing as
that point over there that they have
wrapped around and that they're
connected right at the back over here
let me show the good draw go behind that
they're connected right over there and
that this point and this point are
actually the same point
that they've wrapped around that they've
wrapped around maybe they've wrapped
around actually the way I've drawn it
right here they would actually all repre
right right back there at that point if
I'm visualizing properly but they were
if you go in any one direction you would
come back on the other side of the
surface if you go let's say that Earth
is right here
the way we've depicted it earth is the
center but we see that when when you
look at like this there is no center to
the surface of a sphere even a four
dimensional sphere so in this in this
sense if you go in any one direction
you'll come back out the other side so
if you start from Earth and you go in
that direction once you get there you're
really here again and then you would
come back to Earth and so if this were
the case if the actual volume of the
true universe was smaller than what it
looks like the observable universe and
what's all this stuff on the outside and
to think about it think about what would
happen think about what would happen if
13.7 billion years ago when we were in
that primitive state that you know that
that were that that background radiation
those photons are being that
electromagnetic those electromagnetic
waves were being released let's say they
get released and those photons on their
first pass and I think you know where
this is going on their first pass they
would get to us they would get to us in
about this looks like a distance of
about I don't know this looks like about
six billion years then they would pass
this up and then they would get back to
this point again in another six billion
years and then they would come back here
and so those that very first pass
photons are going to be right over here
and from our point of view we're not
going to see them for a couple of
billion years and so when we do see and
we're going to perceive them we're going
to say wow it took it took 15 16 billion
years for that photon to get to me
that must be from something out here but
the reality is it's a photon from
something within a smaller physical
universe within a smaller actual
universe that's just taken several
passes by us and we're just seeing the
the pass after 14 billion years we just
think it's from something further out
now the other thing is you say well you
know if this was the case if if we could
just go in one direction of the universe
and then come out of the other side and
if all of that was within the observable
universe wouldn't we be able to tell
wouldn't we be able to look in two
directions and see the same thing from a
different perspective and the answer
there is to think about what happens or
actually wouldn't we even be able to see
our cells because if you if if we emit
some light and it would take maybe I
don't know how far that is let's say
that six or seven billion light years to
get right over here which would be right
over there and then it would take
another six or seven billion light years
to get over there so maybe that
background radiation we see is actually
background radiation emitted from that
exact point in space that we are right
now or from a very similar point in
space to where we are right now er part
of the background radiation is from a
similar point in space that we are right
now so how come we can't how come we
can't just see ourselves well I kind of
just answered the question that that
second path if you're observing the same
point in space if you're observing light
from the same point in space on a
previous pass that light was emitted
long long long time ago maybe the 13
billion years ago and so it would be
unrecognizable that region this region
of space the region of space that we are
in right now if we saw the same region
of space thirteen billion years ago we
just wouldn't recognize it now there are
people attempting to see if there is
some pattern see if you can model how
the universe would change and if you see
patterns and and maybe the the actual
universe is a subset of the observable
we just haven't seen it yet but it's
complete it's completely a possibility
hopefully I didn't confuse you I
actually find this kind of an
interesting idea that these things that
we think are this light that we that is
taken thirteen let's say the light
that's taken us eight billion years to
reach us we think it's from something
based on this scale eight billion light
years out it's actually further because
the universe is expanding so would have
actually traversed more space than that
but we think it's from something like
that but it could have been something
further in if the actual universe is
smaller and it's just on its second pass
it's actually coming back again and
that's why it took 8 billion years to
reach us and we don't even recognize it
because it looks very different than
that region of space right now or that
region of space after four billion years
it looks completely different than it
did when it first released anyway
hopefully I didn't confuse you too much
but I
think this is a fascinating fascinating
topic